this is a production of Cornell
University hi everyone my name is keny
Rodriguez I am a PhD student at Cornell
University and today I'm with Steve
reers he's a Horticultural specialist
and today we will talk about harvesting
cantaloup so Steve we know that
sometimes our um cantaloup can grow when
we see them big but we are not sure when
is a good time to harvest so can you
explain us a little bit when can we
Harvest it to have the best ripe uh Cal
with a good flavor right cantaloupes and
muskmelons are actually a lot easier
than watermelons because they go through
a stage that we call a slip stage and
what that means is they slip right off
the vine when they're ripe so this one's
still a little bit early but what you
can do is you can just sort of pull on
it a little bit and when this is ready
and that means the sugar content is just
going to be perfect a little bit of a
little bit of pressure up here would
pull this stem right from the vine and
then you know it's ready but as you can
see this one's not coming off it's still
firmly attached so all this
photosynthates are still going in and
that's what we want but it's much
simpler you'll also notice um the color
will start to change as usually goes
from a a darker green to a lighter green
to almost a yellow um and some of that's
variety as well but again it's the slip
stage is what we're looking for I also
heard that people talk about like
pushing this part and if it like slip
off like pretty easy that's like a sign
that is ripe is that true like whenever
you can push that I I would think that
would be better for determining ripeness
on a fruit Stander in the market because
if it's a little bit softer down here
that probably indicates that it's nice
and ripe and will be good eating if it's
still firm down there that means it was
probably harvested too early okay and
what happen if my food is ready and I
just Harvest it but I don't feel as
sweet as I was expecting what might be
some causes for that and is there
anything that we can do to get it uh
more sweet fruit in the next season or
even whenever these fruits is Ste in the
plant yeah anything you can do to
encourage good healthy green leaves so
that means if you've got if you losing
leaves because of disease that means
you're losing photosynthe you're losing
sugar so make sure you you keep the
leaves as healthy as possible uh that
will be good for this year and then yeah
it's just a matter of of keeping the
plants as healthy as possible healthy
plants lots of photosynth lots of sugars
and other things going into that and
that's what we want does heat um affect
the fruit and do we need like as hot
conditions as for watermelon or you
think they need lower temper a little
bit lower temperatures probably
watermelons are going to do better in
the heat um but again even with melons
once we start getting temperatures over
90° during the day uh that could have an
impact as well on Flavor so we like to
say you know hot and dry but hot you
know we're talking temperatures in the
mid 80s is just perfect uh mid 80s lots
of sunshine the right amount of moisture
when it's needed not again this is
getting close to ripening you can pull
back on that but that's the key are
nutrients like potassium or any other
nutrients on the soil can help out with
the Flav bar or you think that's not um
something that will affect it you know
that's a good question because potassium
is one now most of the time we have
pretty good levels of potassium in the
soils but the only way you're going to
know that is if your soil test and if
your soil pottassium levels are low that
can sometimes affect the flavor not only
of melons but things like tomatoes and
peppers and other things as well so we
want to make sure that our our potassium
levels are optimized because that plays
into photosynthesis and the sugar and
the movement of sugar as well so you
know now what are some of the things
that can cause your cantaloup to not be
as sweet as you want it to be but also
what things you can do and as well today
we learn about when is the right time to
harvest cantaloup so if you have some
cantaloupe and you can see all the
things that we talk about here is the
right time to harvest and enjoy it this
has been a production of Cornell
University
on the web at cornell.edu